in mario paul they are burying their
dead in mass graves
what was unimaginable two weeks ago is
now daily life there's no time for
proper goodbyes in the southern
ukrainian city
days of russian shelling have killed
more than 1 200 people and cut water and
power supplies
we have no gas we have freezing we have
no food man loot here trees have been
cut bodies are being buried in the yards
of the apartment blocks it's so scary we
can't live like this
pray for mariopol we are being bombed
from all directions pray for mothers
with children please it's very hard
and it's getting worse
yet another attack leaves residents in
this part of the city bewildered and
wondering why
russia continues to say its military is
not targeting civilian areas only
ukrainian forces or infrastructure but
no one here believes that in the eastern
city of kharkiv more apartment blocks
and streets are shattered after another
night of shelling
and over the northern city of jotomir
the skies echo with a now familiar sound
[Music]
just now there was another airstrike a
thermal electricity plant was damaged
and a civilian building nearly all of
the windows were blown out of our main
hospital's biggest building and
children's hospital
the fighting has not reached western
ukraine but most people fear that it
won't be long outside the city of levive
agricultural land like this is key to
the war effort
this farm might be far behind the front
lines but the impact of this war is
already being felt
the wars created a renewed sense of duty
for petro and his family farms like his
are essential to help feed people in the
country but he says the conflict is
disrupting production
we are concerned about how we will get
seeds fertilizer and fuel because ports
are now blocked
if we have delays in receiving animal
feed for example it will affect milk
production we need reliable supplies
[Music]
ukrainians continue to do all they can
to help each other and defend their
country but people are getting tired
they want the water end
the only thing i want is for this to be
finished i don't know who's guilty who's
right who started this
them everyone those people who started
this what do i feel
i just have to live on
dreaming about the future becomes
impossible when the present is a
nightmare when people spend their days
battling for survival or being forced to
face their worst fears natasha butler al
jazeera
kulekhev western ukraine